soigner le cancer depuis longtemps c'est
l'ambition des chercheurs et ils ne sont
pas les seuls
l'aventuré de châteauroux défraie la
chronique des apprentis cancérologue se
donne aussi la mission d'éradiquer le
fléau et leurs méthodes sont parfois
disons controversé jours le cabinet
provincial est l inventeur d'un remède
le fait l'ena capable prétendent et ils
devaient en particulier de cancer et la
tuberculose
on l'appelait le docteur miracle il y à
gagner une trentaine de millions la
prison de la santé après aujourd'hui le
docteur miracle inculpé d'escroquerie à
la santé publique
trente quatre ans plus tard en 1983 un
italien se vantait lui de dons
surnaturels pour guérir les malades
parmi ces 3500 miracle plusieurs
guérisons de cancer ce miraculé y
croyait dur comme fer avait un cancer du
pancréas un guérisseur l'apôtre est venu
vous voir
oui il venait souvent même avant il vous
a imposé les mains
exactement vous êtes senti mieux oui
tout de suite
vraiment tout de suite j'ai ressenti
comme une décharge électrique comme une
secouse ses supposés miracle ne furent
pas du goût de l'archevêque de sienne en
toscane et l'excommunier à l'apôtre et
toute sa communauté les accusant
d'hérésie et de schisme
[Musique]
les magiciens du cancer dans les années
90 certains malades désespéré continuer
d'y croire
exemple en 1997 cette femme n'espérait
plus rien de la médecine traditionnelle
donc je pense qu'il faut quelque chose
que tu chocolat métiers des croyances
entretenu depuis longtemps par quelques
prétendus devant une grande question qui
concerne
entier c'est le cancer alors si vous me
permettez je ne vais pas en avant de
cristal sans boule de cristal mais à
grand renfort de vision astral 7
astrologue prédisait en 1966 la fin
imminente du cancer leucémie le cancer
bats pour cette année bien sûr mais
enfin on peut penser que pour la fin 76
faire un très bon résultat
disons comme on l'a stoppé la
tuberculose chômage n'aura pas dit vrai
le cancer est toujours l'une des
premières causes de mortalité dans le
monde selon l'om est ce plus de 8
millions de personnes en meurent encore
chaque année
[Musique]